you uh mentioned uh and applebaum's book
red famine yeah Stars war in Ukraine but
another excellent book on on the topic
and by the way thank you for
recommending that to me so it was
um her work's amazing yeah it's it's a
really really powerful
uh book about not just about hanamore
but like the context of Ukraine
basically the history of Ukraine that's
relevant for today yeah
to understand understand the the
relationship between Russia and Ukraine
uh but another great book is bloodlands
Europe between Hitler and Stalin by
Timothy Snyder I don't know I think you
also recommend that to me at some point
or maybe not I haven't but I'm I'm
familiar with I haven't read it uh so he
he does quite a bit of as brief but
extremely well researched writing about
cannibalism there okay and that it was
not uncommon during the Stalin imposed
famine in the Soviet Ukraine for parents
to cook and eat their children he writes
quote survival was immoral as well as a
physical struggle a woman doctor wrote
to a friend in June 1933 that she had
not yet become a cannibal but was not
sure that it shall not be won by the
time my letter reaches you
in quotes the good people died first
those who refused to steal or to
prostitute themselves died those who
gave food to others died those who
refused to eat corpses died those who
refused to kill their fellow man died
parents who resisted cannibalism died
before their children did and their
stories in there about
um
yeah cooking cooking your children
the the other thing about cannibalism
about famine in general that stood out
to me that unlike a lot of atrocities
is uh the people that are starving are
exhausted they're they're basically
unable to think
so they don't even have the energy to
protest
it's a it's a strange kind of way
to kill thinking in the populace
that that it kind of I suppose it was
obvious
but there's something fundamental about
starvation where it's slowly removes
your Humanity
um
yeah there's a there was a scene in the
book where um
a lot of times people literally go crazy
and there's a scene where Mom it's some
nursing train station was nursing her
kid and she was you know going mad from
hunger and she just starts beating the
crap out of her baby and kicking it and
then she just refers to normal like
nothing had happened uh yeah Madness
like yeah yeah you lose yeah you lose
your mind yeah yeah and uh I mean I
don't know what the physiological cause
of this it's not it's I think it's you
know if someone has dealt with a
glycogen depletion it affects their mood
things like that so taken to an extreme
who knows what happens when parts of the
brain start functioning and start
imploding